en fait rencontrer dans un rétroviseur
je ne sais pas exactement comment je
suis redevenu homosexuels d'ailleurs je
bats je dois te dire que j'ai une femme
sont en forme
oh mon dieu alors dans ma vie amoureuse
elle était si tu veux ballotté entre
hommes et femmes
mais là que tout à fait heureuse c'est
que je me suis toujours adaptés à la
fonction tu peux y avoir je pouvais
faire la femme et l'homme
il faisait si beau le soleil était si
chaud et nous si nu c'était le
bouleversement total comment une vie
bascule à travers une main qui
s'aventurent
le scandale à cette époque c'était de le
revendiquer
c'est contre nature ce qu'ils font quand
même en moi je trouve ça dégoûtant
alors les mal baisées oui oui au des mal
baisées oui oui tu as trouvé que j'ai
une période je m'habillais comme une
folle mais le souvenir que j'en ai c'est
que ça m'a fait énormément de bien ça
m'a libéré
et puis parce que on était quand même
des marginaux c'est à dire qu on était
la marginalité nous rendent est libre un
monsieur mettre un jeune homme
mode surtout ne nous voilons pas
aujourd'hui on a rigolé on en aurait
pleuré ya onze ans par l'esa de ça comme
une maladie ça te mettait en doute quand
même été classé dans les maladies pic le
chasseur à la biche quand ils ont des
cheveux gris des cheveux blancs jeux
jeux flash comme on aura maintenant un
monsieur et l'étain jeune homme
à chaque fois les fois dans le métro je
les vieux ou les vieilles qui me
plairait bien